the International Criminal Court is a
huge opportunity for the Obama
administration although if I were
advising with the new president obama i
would tell him don't touch it for at
least a year you've got enough on your
plate don't make this like gays in the
military where it's something very
controversial and you get out there on
it early but actually it poisons the
well for a lot of other things but the
reason I say it's a great opportunity is
because what has been lacking above all
on the International Criminal Court is
just plain leadership there has never
been a presidential address on what the
court is and what it could do President
Clinton ultimately supported the court
at the very end of his administration
there was a period around 1995 where he
was he supported it but as the court was
actually being created he had lots of
other things to occupy his time he was
not in good shape with the military